mossy nation the other day i was
approached by service-based brick and
mortar business and they have a very
profitable single location model and
they wanted to figure out a way or what
path was going to be the best vehicle
for them to make the most money and so
we had a really good conversation about
this and they broke down the different
paths they could take um and for them it
was really valuable and they were very
happy about it and so what i wanted to
do was break down this exact same
process for you
so if you have a service-based business
or something where you have labor of
some sort that you
rent out at a profit to other people to
provide value then this video is for you
and if you want to figure out a way to
package those services in a way that is
that is uh that has a lot of enterprise
value that has a lot of cash flow while
you're growing then this video is for
you okay so i'm gonna break down the
only four ways that i know of that you
can package your service and the labor
and knowledge that you have into a
profitable business now some of these
have pros in terms they provide more
cash flow have higher margin or lower
operational drag others provide more
enterprise value but a little bit more
difficult to create so i'm going to show
you the pros and cons of each of them i
have businesses i own businesses that
have three in three of these four
categories right so i feel like i can
speak to these with a decent amount of
knowledge and not with a bias towards
one or the other all right so the first
is a privately held chain all right so
i'll put private chain everyone uh you
know keep your pg hats on so a private
chain is basically like you have one
location and then you open a second and
a third and the specific business i was
talking to was a person who had a salon
concept so they did a concept around
hair uh and he was doing very well and
they were like man you know we're
thinking about opening more locations
and we want to figure out the best way
to do this or ultimately make money with
this model all right so the first is is
just you open another location then
another location another location you
return you return retain all the
ownership rights you take all the risk
you front all the capital you hire all
the labor you control the brand um but
you own everything end to end all right
so this is a privately held chain all
right this is the first of the four
vehicles that you can use to ultimately
build your wealth all right at the end
i'll show you the pros and cons of each
of them the second some of you may be
familiar with hopefully you've
definitely frequented one of these
businesses as a franchise so subway
mcdonald's you know jiffy lube you know
all of these are franchises right they
are they are a single model that has
been franchised out people buy in
investors typically so this is a
different person here an investor who's
outside who just wants to find a good
return of capital will buy into a
franchise model and typically because
franchises have far lower
uh failure rates than starting your own
business and so that's the advantage of
this is that in theory there's lower
risk now i could talk about the
actuality behind that which is very
different i could also tell you about
the tons and tons and tons of franchises
don't actually make money i think it's
like 90 or 95 of franchises never get
past 100 locations which candidly if
you're doing a franchise model you need
to get past 100 to make any real money
and you were like how is that even
possible i'll break it down in a second
all right so that is the second vehicle
that you can use in a service-based
business to make a fortune now number
three number three is a licensing model
and i'll tell you some of the pros of
this one a licensing model you might not
be as familiar with the businesses that
use licensing because depending on how
they structure the license to you have
to differentiate from what a franchise
is a franchise has three components you
have name
business systems and fee all right so if
you have all three of those things and
people are using your brand your
business systems and your fee then you
are a franchise and if you're operating
as a license and you're using those
three components then you are an illegal
franchise all right then you can get tat
you can get fined and you can shut down
and all that kind of stuff it's paying
the butt i'll talk about the pros and
cons of licensing in a second but that
is the third vehicle all right so in a
licensing vehicle you're typically gonna
have two of those three things so you
could have for example crossfit is a
licensing right they give you the name
and they have a fee but they don't have
business systems a different version
would be
let's say you had a model that worked
really well you license all the stuff
but it's white labeled all right so you
have a fee and you have business systems
but you don't have a name or a brand
that they have to adhere to all right
that would be a licensing model so
there's different versions of this um
but that is essentially what a third way
that you could package your existing
knowledge or ip uh in a way that scales
to multiple locations and ultimately
make an enterprise that is very valuable
the fourth and it's felt worth
mentioning is software and i and i bring
this up because it depends on the type
of service you offer now if you're
cutting hair you probably can't replace
it with software right but if you are
providing some sort of service that
software can do
um then this would be software attack
enabled service all right hopefully you
can read that tech enabled service all
right so i'd say number four is is
either of those for most people who have
a service based business it will
probably be one through three and the
reason i bring that up is because if
you're not already really good at
software and have a software co-founder
who knows how to code knows user
experience knows how to build
engineering teams if you don't have
something like that do not try and
outsource it to a third party team i
promise you it will probably not work
all right now you i promise you it won't
work all right just please just two
million three million dollars of
development later i've made the mistakes
let me give you a three million dollar
gift don't do it i told you that i have
three of these four and so let's go
through the advantages or disadvantages
that i walk through with this particular
business all right so a private chain
is gonna have the highest costs
of opening each location so there's
incremental cost every new location you
have to do the build out you have to
negotiate you have to find the location
you have to negotiate the leases you
have to you have to build everything out
and then you have the risk of the lease
for the duration of the time on top of
that you have to staff it you control
the employees etc now when is a private
chain uh something that is worthwhile so
i would say i'm looking at two main
things where a private chain would be
worth considering first is that they
have low costs of build out right so if
it doesn't cost a lot of money to build
a new location so let's say if it costs
less than you know forty or fifty
thousand dollars to build a location now
that's an absolute number but relative
to the income that it generates let's
say it generates four hundred thousand a
year in profit if it costs you i should
probably put a percentage on this but i
would say if it costs you less than six
months worth of profit in the first year
to open a new location then it would be
it would make sense to open a private
chain so a great example of this would
be insomnia cookies all right these tiny
little locations they just had i think
they were like 800 square feet on
average they're tiny they just have to
put an oven in there and a front door
window and they have lots of delivery
and for them they had tons of margin
because it was cookies they were selling
flour and sugar for big margins and the
amount that a location could make it was
tremendous compared to the cost all
right and so here it's very low to build
very high profit and so it's worth
owning the entire thing all right that's
a private chain so some of the biggest
brands in the world start as private
chains and then they go direct to
consumers so chanel louis vuitton
christian dior you know i mean all of
these are brands they had brick and
mortar locations they owned everything
because the amounts of to build out a
store compared to the amount of profit
it made was almost nothing now that is a
product business not a service business
but i'm still at least explaining the
point the third piece is that um it's
low service requirements so the more
specialized you are in terms of the
types of skills that are required to do
the business or provide the value the
more difficult it is to scale in a
private setting all right and that is
because it is inconsistency of service
will be a problem so if you're very good
at your thing and you have your location
and it works well if if you are required
to make that level of value provided to
the end consumer that it's not going to
be a scalable model all right the reason
that subway for example works is because
anybody can make a sandwich that tastes
the same way if you use the same recipes
and use the same process right now if
you can productize your service in such
a way that you minimize the variability
and you can decrease the skill
requirements of the labor that is is
required to work that system then you
have a very scalable model which is the
goal so private chain
so for example for us just as a side
note we have one of our businesses that
is a private chain and they were
actually they were in a licensing model
right and when they came in as
acquisition.com portfolio company i
actually moved them over here because
candidly their licensees were making so
much money using their system and it
cost so little to open new locations
that i was like we should just be owning
all this revenue it's not worth
just giving all the revenue away and
giving all the trade secrets right and
so we transitioned the business over and
in the last uh 14 months took it from a
half a million dollar your business to a
12 million a year business pretty cool
right so that is number one the second
is franchise right so pros and cons of
franchises cons very very litigious very
expensive to start it usually costs
about 750 000
uh to start a franchise just in terms of
the setup fees and legal and and filings
and all that kind of stuff that you have
to do in order and that's just if that's
just to get started that's not even to
get it going and to really build a
franchise the right way most times it
takes one to two years to really start
seeing profits because you'll sell
locations but the cost of selling
franchisees that franchise upfront fee
will typically only cover the cost of
acquisition all right so what it costs
you to get franchise leads from
franchise brokers or people who want to
buy investments it'll usually cost you
almost the entire upfront fee which is
usually about 50 grand for many
franchises
and so you're only going to make money
once they open off of royalties from top
line all right so it's a very slow model
but
the enterprise value of a franchise is
extremely high so enterprise value the
ev on both of these is very good all
right for private chain and franchise
both of them are very good but the
franchise multiple only comes off of the
corporate franchise revenue because
technically you're selling llc's to
other people so other people are the
owners of the vast majority of the
profit of the business right so you're
only making your money off of the
royalties that are coming in and then
you still have all of your costs of
running your actual franchise helping
the franchisees succeed etc now when you
would start a franchise would be
something where you have very very high
build up costs right if a new location
costs a ton of money like mcdonald's
right costs whatever a million bucks to
open mcdonald's that's a lot of capital
right and so
you would want to give you want to give
that risk that capital risk to other
people you basically crowdsource for
lack of a term the ownership of these
new locations and then you take a piece
off the top now mcdonald's obviously
owns the real estate too because they're
very smart cookies that is uh the
franchise model in a nutshell right
you're running on a very small
percentage of top line and you have to
have lots and lots of locations and if
you guys want a rule of thumb you
usually need to have 100 plus locations
for a franchise really to make sense and
here's a fun fact for you 90 to 95
percent of franchises don't hit over 100
locations all right so as much as people
have service-based business and think
that the ultimate goal is to build a
franchise so that someday they can
franchise their business the franchise
is not the end goal it is the beginning
of the next journey all right you have
not yet succeeded you might impress your
parents and your friends but you will
not impress your bank accounts or the
players in the game who really
understand how it works all right so
number one private chain number two
franchise opportunity number three
licensing all right the advantage here
is that it it it's the lowest cost so
almost no cost to license out a model
typically you have super high margins
just like franchising does the margins
are high in franchising it just costs a
lot to start so high margins now the
problems with this is that it's
not that defensible it's very hard to
defend and there's very little
enterprise value so very low multiples
when you sell unless you have a
ridiculously sticky licensing agreement
all right so for you for an idea if
anyone's curious you would want to have
80
plus
yearly retention on licensees for for
you to get a real really attractive uh
exit multiple right so we're talking you
know six plus multiple on the exit all
right and so now the advantage of
licensing is that it doesn't cost you
any money it's very high cash flow
throughout the process and you can
pretty much make money day one right and
so when you're newer sometimes licensing
makes the most sense right so uh gym
launch that business is a licensing
business right and it was my first
business i didn't
have tons of money um you know to get it
going and i wanted to start generating
cash flow sooner and so that was why i
did that the business that we have um
i won't i won't sure what it is because
we try not to get people to copy what
we're doing um but in uh in one of our
niches uh like i said earlier we went
from having a licensing model to owning
a ton of locations right now we have 12
locations and we open a new location
every month which is pretty cool number
four software
so if you have a way and this requires a
ton of cost to build lots of time very
low cash flow you're like why would i do
software it's because the enterprise
value on the exit is usually the highest
but again everyone likes to hear that oh
i heard you can exit software for a ton
yeah but the same requirement of churn
is still 80 or higher yearly uh
retention right and the higher you make
that retention it's got to be above 80
percent or no one's even consider you a
software they're just going to consider
you a normal service that just has some
tech element to it all right and so each
of these has pros and cons and so if
you're thinking about scaling your
service based business i'll think of
which of these four buckets do you fit
in and which of these strategies makes
the most sense for you all right and so
this is how i look at service-based
businesses if i'm going to come in as an
investor and i want to help them scale
or triple or or 5x in you know five year
period i'm going to say which of these
vehicles is going to make most sense for
the ip and the value that we're
providing based on the model that exists
the cash flow that i require the amount
of upfront investment the time to go and
a lot of times just the appetite risk of
the entrepreneur and how unbel and how
structurally sound the return is on the
model so if we know beyond a shadow of a
debt that when we enter a mark we're
gonna freaking murder it and it costs us
not a lot of money to open it then we're
gonna own the whole thing privately now
same thing if we know we're going to
kill it but it costs a million bucks to
open a location then we might franchise
right and if it costs no money right and
we don't think that it's a really
protectable ip right let's say it's a
more offer based business like jim
launch for example in the beginning was
a very offer driven business offer is
very easy to copy right and so it was
how quickly can we take as much market
share as we possibly can so for
licensing it's speed right you can you
can you can absolutely outpace anyone
else in the market on speed and you make
lots of cash flow but you're going to
sacrifice a lot of money on the exit
right and so with licensing you make
money throughout the process
rather than having a big lump at the end
and probably the exact opposite with
that would be like a software type thing
so if you take the time develop the
software you put the cache up front to
develop it you figure out a way to do it
and then ultimately figure out a way to
make it as valuable as as you have to
achieve this 80 or higher uh yearly
retention on the customers that you are
selling or it will not be valuable at
all and it will be valued like the other
ones except you just wasted a bunch of
money and time so i hope this uh
provided value for you if you're if
you're thinking about how to ultimately
create your enterprise in a way that has
the most value then i would think
through each of these four different
vehicles um as monetization structures
uh for the opportunity all right so lots
of mozzie nation if you don't know who i
am my name is oxford mozilla and
acquisition.com our portfolio is about
85 million a year in revenue and i have
nothing to sell you so if you like this
hit subscribe and if you did i love you
either way i'll catch you guys next
video bye